I'm sorry if I I will ask another
question so speaking about Fallen Angels
cuz I met a preacher before and we were
talking about these things but he said
those the sons of God does not
necessarily mean that those were Fallen
Angels
but they can tell you it doesn't mean
that if you read contextually in the
context itself and then you read in
light of New Testament they are
angels uh I'll here I'll prove it to you
if you go to Genesis 6 verses 1 and two
open it up go to Genesis 6 1-2
Genesis 6 1 and 2 now it came to pass
when men began to multiply on the first
of because I'm GNA unpack it for you
notice it says men in general
men not some men it says men right yes
had what began to multiply on the face
of the Earth and daughters were born to
them that the sons of God saw the
daughters of men okay now before
MH in verse one it says men had
daughters born to them is that referring
to men in general or some men men in
general but then in verse two it tells
you the daughters of men so here you
have the daughters of men so here the
daughters and here the men who had them
but they are differentiated from the
sons of God if the sons of God were men
then they wouldn't be included in that
category of men right yes sir so why are
they differentiated why are they
distinguished yeah I understand what
you're saying and I get it but their
objection was maybe those sons of God
were simply like Servants of God because
they're called how can they be Servants
of God when they do something sinful and
evil and bring about the destruction of
the
world exactly these sons of God were
they righteous or evil because through
their having sex with these women God
got disgusted with the world and
humanity and destroyed it that sounds
like righteous Servants of God no they
do not okay so contextually they cannot
be righteous Servants of God when
they're doing something so horrible and
evil that God destroys the World by
flood wow right yes sir now the second
proof the second proof it's angels and
not humans is second Peter and Jude go
to Second Peter chapter 2 you ready yes
sir okay in second Peter chapter 2 now
let's let me give you the context so you
understand what Peter's doing and J
you're going to do the same thing in
second Peter
to Peter is warning that they're going
to be false teachers who are going to
deny
Jesus whom God will destroy and then he
gives an example of how God treated
false teachers in the past to prove that
since God doesn't change God is the same
yesterday today and forever you know
that if God destroyed false teachers and
evildoers in the in the past he will do
so in the future right yes sir and then
he gives three examples of God
destroying false teachers false prophets
and evildoers for their sins as a
warning these false teachers and their
evil their immorality will be destroyed
as well three examples from the Old
Testament that Peter assumes you the
reader know where to find them now
notice the three examples he gives go to
Second Peter 2 read 4 to8 4 8 it says
for if God did not spare the Angels who
sinned but cast them down to Hell and
delivered them into the chains of
Darkness to be reserved for judgment
five and did not spare the ancient world
but saved Noah one of eight people a
preacher of righteousness bringing in
the flood on the world of the ungodly
six and turning the cities of Sodom and
gomorra into ashes condemned them to
destruction making them an example to
those who afterward would live
ungodly all the way to eight right all
the way to eight okay and delivered
righteous Lord who was oppressed by the
filthy conduct of the wicked eight for
that righteous man dwelling among them
tormented his his righteous soul from
day to day by seeing and hearing their
lowless
deeds okay now now only is lot called
the righteous man who has a righteous
soul and who was burning with anger what
he was seeing but notice these
stories are to be found in the Old
Testament so we know lot Sodom Gora
that's Genesis 18:19 right yes sir we
don't know in the flood that Genesis 678
right yes sir where's the story of the
Angels if Peter is telling you about
stories in the Old Testament how God
destroyed the wicked and evil and he
gives you the story of Noah and the
flood well you know where that right yes
and he tells you lot you know where to
find that right yes sir but then Peter
assumes you'll be able to find the story
of angels being punished in the Old
Testament so where in the Old Testament
do you find the story of angels being
punished for
sin uh in the story of Noah when God
brought the flood there's only one the
sons of God story otherwise what other
story
could Peter be appealing to as an
example of even angels being punished
for sin there is no other place besides
Genesis
6 right yes
sir and we know that angels are called
sons of God because in job
38:7 job 38:7 it says when God laid the
foundation of the earth and he created
the foundation of the earth it says all
the sons of God rejoiced With God when
he created the Earth well there were no
human beings at that time who were the
sons of God that rejoice when God
created the Earth before humans existed
Angels okay and this is why some of the
oldest Jewish interpretations even say
the sons of God were angels for example
The Book of Enoch if you read The Book
of Enoch we found a section of Enoch in
the Dead Sea Scrolls and it's translated
English online when you read The Book of
Enoch a copy of it written in Hebrew
before the time of Christ you'll find
that in Enoch it even gives you the
names of these
angels yeah their names I've read okay
so here now you have a Jewish Source
before the time of Christ that says
those sons of God were angels and now go
to Jude because Jude even quotes The
Book of Enoch go to Jude it's one
chapter 25
verses okay so when you go to Jude let
me show you where Jude is quoting The
Book of Enoch and this quotation
you'll actually find in The Book of
Enoch that we discovered in 1947
translated in English in the English
it's it's the Book of Enoch chapter 1
verse 9 chapter 1 verse 9 The Book of
Enoch this is quoted word for word in
Jude go to Jude read verses 14 and 15 14
and
15 it says now Enoch the seventh from
Adam prophesied about this man also
saying behold the Lord comes with
10,000s of his Saints to execute that
judgment on all to convict all who are
ungodly among them of all their ungodly
Deeds which they have committed in an
ungodly way and of all the harsh things
which ungodly Sinners have spoken
against him okay here he quotes a
prophecy from Enoch the seven from Adam
now let me show you where that prophecy
is I just sent you the link and I posted
it on the screen here's the English
translation of the Book of Enoch chapter
1 verse 9 tell me if this sounds
familiar okay you just read the prophecy
right now look look at here I'm gonna
put on the screen guys tell me he just
read Jude 1: 14- 15 tell me what I'm
about to post to you if it sounds
familiar this is now the English
translation of Enoch chapter 1 verse 9 I
gave you the link now watch here guys
let me just line it all up
let me read it tell me if it sounds
familiar 1 Enoch 1:9 and behold he
cometh with 10,000s of his holy ones to
execute judgment upon upon all and to
destroy all the ungodly and to convict
All Flesh of all the works of their
ungodliness which they have ungodly
committed and of all the hard things
which ungodly Sinners have spoken
against them does that sound familiar
yes sir didn't you just read out in Jude
yes sir so that tells you that when Jude
wrote this epistle by inspiration Holy
Spirit This Book of Enoch was in
existence and he had access to it
because he's quoting from
it which means that Jude accepts many of
the ideas and teachings in Enoch as true
and
historical yes sir and it's in this book
that we told that the sons of God were
Angels so now go to Jude same chapter
read 5-
7 5-7 it says but I want to remind you
though you once knew this you once knew
this that the Lord having saved the
people out of the land of Egypt
afterward destroyed those who did not
believe and the angels who did not keep
their proper domain but left their own
aboard he has reserved in Everlasting
chains under Darkness for the Judgment
of the Great day as Sodom and gomorra
and the cities around them in a similar
manner to this wait wait wait did you
catch it read six again because you
catch the connection with seven what did
six say and the angels who did not keep
their proper domain but left their own
abod so they left Heaven their proper
domain so they came to the world they
left their Heavenly aboe they didn't
retain their position and they came down
okay go ahead he has reserved in
Everlasting chains and darkness for the
Judgment of the great day now now
compare it with seven watch here as
Sodom and gomorra and the cities around
them in a similar manner to this having
given themselves over to sexual
immorality now you confuse me it says
Sodom and
Gomorrah did a similar thing that the
Angels did Sodom gorra and the
neighboring cities in a similar manner
meaning similar to the angels gave
themselves to sexual immorality so what
was the sins of the Angels sexual
immorality you caught it yes sir so
Sodom gomorah committed a similar sin to
the angels what was the sin of Sodom
Gomorrah sexual immorality
homosexuality rape and orgies it says
this sin was similar to what the Angels
did because the Angels also committed
sexual immorality because angels are not
supposed to have sex with humans just
like a man is not supposed to have sex
with men or gang rape or
ories but now let me ask you another
question the story of Sodom Gomorrah is
in Genesis 18:19 right yes sir the story
of God Jesus Christ Our Lord bringing
Israel out of Egypt Into the Wilderness
and then punishing them in the
wilderness verse five that's in the book
of Exodus right yes sir so where do we
find the story of the Angels because
Jude like Peter assumes you're going to
find the story in your Old Testament
in Genesis that's the only
place now here are the names of the
Angels according to Enoch here's the
link again Enoch here it is online for
free translate English here it is guys
chapter six here it is I gave you the
link let me post it chapter six it gives
you their names here you go I'm going to
break it down into
two watch here
okay and it came to pass When the
Children of Men had multiplied that in
those days were born unto them beautiful
and comly daughters and the angels the
children of Heaven saw and lusted after
them and said to one another come let us
choose us wives from among the children
of men and beget us children and S Jaa
who was their leader it even gives you
their names said unto them I fear you
will not indeed agree to do this deed
and I alone shall have to pay the
penalty of a great sin and they all
answered him and said let us all swear
an oath and all bind ourselves by Mutual
impr imprecations meaning we'll call
God's curse on us if we don't do this
let me quote the rest of it right not to
abandon here he goes the rest of it not
to
abandon this plan but to do this this
thing then swear they all together and
bound themselves by Mutual imprecations
meaning invoking curses on them if they
don't do this and they were in all 200
so even gives you the number 200 who
descended in the days of Jared on the
summit of Mount Herman and they called
it Mount Herman because they had sworn
and bound themselves by Mutual
imprecations upon it and these are the
names of their leaders now it gives you
the names of the angel
some
lazas their leader
AR
R Tam R Dan
eel
Barak these
names
Aros an Zak
Sam J these are the
Chiefs of tens there you go yes sir so I
hope you got your answer yes sir I got
my answer thank you very much any other
questions or this is this is it